[Music]
well hey everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout if this is your first
time joining us today hello it's so nice
to meet you I'm Rachel I lead customer
marketing at posit if this is your first
data science hangout say hi in the chat
too because we all want to welcome you
in here uh espec ESP anybody joining for
the first time this is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear about what's going on in the world
of data across all different Industries
we're here every Thursday at the same
time same place so if you are watching
on YouTube later sometime in the future
and you want to join us live you can use
the link below to add it to your
calendar at the Hangouts we're all
dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everybody love to hear
from everyone no matter your years of
experience your titles your languages
you work in or
industry and it's totally okay if you
just want to listen in here maybe this
is your lunch break or you're out for a
walk or something but if you want to
jump in and add some context to
something or ask questions you can raise
your hand on zoom and I'll keep an eye
out you could put questions in in the
zoom chat and feel free to just put a
little star next to it if it's something
you want me to read out loud
instead um and then lastly we also have
a slido link where you can ask questions
anonymously which I realize I forgot to
create so I will create that in one of
the first questions and then we'll share
it in the the chat here um but with that
I am so excited to introduce my two
co-hosts for today Joseph power hours
principal data scientists at in and Jen
Wing forly VP of product and growth at
thread up and I I thought today was a
really fun example of how community and
data friends happen um I met Joe at the
posit conference um recently and we had
a bit of an impromptu pizza party with
Javier and seep from the Hangouts here
too and then Joe Al introduced me to Jen
here as well so I'd love to have you
both introduce yourself and share a
little bit about your background also
something you like to do outside of work
too Jen you should leave talk oh no okay
um so I'm Jen Wong I um yeah was at
thread up which is an online Marketplace
for secondhand clothing for five years
um and before that um had done a PhD in
kind of Behavioral Science uh looking at
you know environmental decision making
um Joe and I met during grad school
actually taking a bunch of classes but
one of them being really the data
science class that probably turned us
both into Data scientists um and so I'm
really excited to be here and um have
spent a lot of time thinking about
career and and all these things is
something that Joe and I have talked
about over the last many many years um
and then outside of work I mean I love
to do a lot of things but most recently
I've been cooking a lot a lot um so I'll
just mention
that um yeah I um had several careers
previous to this one um was initially
was a Furniture maker uh for seven years
and um I started teaching Woodworking
and and became interested in like
questions around like students
motivation and how people like
perception of their environment uh can
like improve their their learning
outcomes um and so that led to uh yeah
getting a PhD in educational psychology
and I had to learn programming and St
statistics along the way and uh these
data science jobs emerged in Silicon
Valley around the same time uh so uh
that was uh that's that that brought me
here um outside of work uh I I still
enjoy uh furniture making um I'm just
grateful not to have to rely on it for
my primary income anymore um so yeah I
see some love for your hobbies in the
chat here Javier I thought you had a
quick follow-up question for Jen oh yes
um have you asked what I enjoy cooking
and I was thinking about I was like well
my mistake is I often buy Vine veggies
from Costco so then I have to figure out
like many recipes for the same
ingredient awesome well let's we'll jump
in here I get to ask some of the
questions in the beginning while we wait
for questions to come in from everybody
um but at the Hangouts we do often talk
a bit about um hiring but it's more
often from the employer side but think
thinking more from the the candidate
side um I know somebody had reached out
to to me about that last week too I know
you both have some experience
transitioning from Academia to Industry
um and would' love to just learn a
little bit from you about maybe some
tips you might have for us or people are
in a similar position Jo I'll let you go
first okay
um yeah I uh reflecting on my own uh
path and then I I also still speak with
a lot of people uh regularly who are
transitioning and um I'll try to offer
the advice that I wish I had you know
six years ago um which is that like if
you're coming out of an academic
background it's easy to feel like you're
you're not qualified or you're
unprepared for uh Tech careers in
industry
and and that's really really far from
the truth you're actually you have an
incredibly unique and valued skill set
uh the challenge is learning how to talk
about it in ways that a non-academic is
going to recognize and I hope that's
something you get out of to
St um and so and this doesn't just apply
to academics you know if you had a
career previously in like nonprofit work
or government work and you know you're
thinking about transitioning to Tech I I
think a lot of this is going to apply
for you too um and so what are the big
things like I think it would be easy to
miss uh your soft
skills I don't use that soft term
dismissively at all they are the most
valuable skills and these are things
like the ability to take a vaguely
scoped problem and turn it into an
actionable line of research um if you
finished the PHD you know how to do that
um other factors like your ability to
translate your expertise to to people
who are intelligent but don't share your
particular expertise um that is a huge
uh skill set uh you know in order for
you to have influence within your
organization uh you're going to need to
translate your expertise to leaders and
other stakeholders who you know don't
have your particular background um and
you got a lot of practice in public
presentation and translation uh during
your academic experience that most
people never get I was never formally
trained in Public Presentation until I
got into my PhD program and then just
out of like self-preservation you know
your lab members to Pro protect the uh
you know reputation and integrity of the
lab they're going to give you a lot of
guided feedback on how to present uh
well um so it's it's easy to get hung up
on like oh I I don't know how to do this
particular modeling technique in Python
and it's
like those are the hard skills in the
sense of like soft skills but you can
learn those pretty quick uh you're
bringing in a lot of soft skills that
that are very very rare they're so rare
they're not going to be in the job
posting a lot of times you're going to
need to proactively plug them uh
throughout your resume throughout the
interview process and I promise you you
will see the hiring managers uh uh perk
up when they start hearing about these
really rare abilities uh that you've had
the last five six years to develop yeah
I I guess to to add on to that I think
um one there are two things that kind of
come to mind for me here is that one is
that um expertise is truly relative
right anybody who works in Industry
knows this you easily are the expert on
XYZ thing in your organization because
as long as you provide as long as you
know more about that than any body else
in your organization you are the
resident expert and I think that um when
I was transitioning that was one thing
that I worried about is oh I don't know
enough um but I was just talking to
somebody yesterday and I was telling her
like you already know way more about
this industry than anybody I've ever
hired um and 10 out of 10 times I would
rather take somebody who knows a little
bit less about the industry but has a
proven track record of being able to
learn very quickly and can pick it up
right so I think that's something that
anybody's who's in this room is clearly
interested in learning and um is curious
and wants to improve their skills so I
have no doubt about that that's kind of
the first thing like expertise is
relative um and then the second one is
kind of you know what Joe was saying is
you're trying to translate your skills
into something that your audience and
people who are hiring can understand one
of the best pieces of advice I got was
from um David Kelly who kind of
established the design thinking method
and and the D school at Stanford and he
really talked about how you know every
industry and every organ organization is
really just a group of people who get
together and kind of decide what the
standards are right and you all know
this in data science the standards in
data science have been evolving and
shifting and what's really high quality
and and The Cutting Edge has changed a
lot and so in order to actually
understand how to translate your skills
into what's most valuable I personally
think one of the only ways that you can
do it is you have to talk to people and
you have to talk to a lot of people to
understand how they
um what like even the specific words
that they use to describe certain skills
can be sort of signals to them that you
know or understand how things will work
um and so I remember going to David
Kelly and saying like oh I'm debating
between these two jobs right now one is
um like position a and the other one is
position B do you think if I take
position B it'll make it hard for me to
do position a stuff later on and he was
like Jen like I'm not an expert in this
field but but it's knowable and if you
don't understand the answer yet it's
because you haven't talked to enough
people in the field you need to talk to
enough people to like wrap your arms
around the Norms of that group and then
you'll know the answer um so I think the
takeaway there for me is like you need
to talk to people to understand what
they value and and how the community
works but also that it's knowable I
think a lot of people assume that you
can't get that kind of understanding
until you've been working in that
industry for multiple years and
certainly your understanding will you
know you'll get a lot more once you work
in it but if you talk to a lot of people
you can get like 80 90% of the way there
for a job decision I think I want to
jump on top of that one because it's
really it's really good about talking to
people um LinkedIn is an incredible tool
for making the
transition um and maybe like well I
don't know a lot of people in Industry
yet I didn't oh I didn't either at one
point and actually you'll find that cold
calling on LinkedIn can be very very
effective um I typically look for people
who had like a PhD in their name or who
I could see had some academic background
or some background similar to mine and
then just Reach Out say like look I I'm
trying to make the transition could you
spare 15 minutes to talk to me these can
be very vulnerable conversations um you
you're not trying to impress them right
now you're trying like as Jen was saying
to get like a lay of the land and to
scope like how your skills might fit in
and overwhelmingly those people actually
turn into your backers like they'll
submit your resume internally um really
just after an hour meeting um like
they'll see that you're like a
thoughtful resourceful person and you
know you're a safe bet um but to Jen's
Point like you learn the lay of the land
um so that you you're better prepared to
talk about your skills and and what you
have to offer and and also to know for
where You' fit in absolutely I see um
Ceda you had a question in the chat a
bit earlier do you want to jump in
sure my camera always acts if oh there
we go
hey so I was really intrigued by the
conversation about transitioning from
Academia to Industry um and I would
really like to understand because um
hopefully that's a direction I would
want to pursue because I am a pure
biologist trying to transition into data
science and I work at the data science
lab now at the hot and kind of really
trying to understand where I go from
knowing all this intense biology
knowledge which is purely bench skills
and now moving into more genomics and
Technology driven and using um you know
these uh newer uh Technologies to really
understand and answer genomics questions
but for me what has been interesting in
this even medium shift from being in the
lab to being in a data science lab where
people are focusing on building more
reproducible workflows Etc one thing
that I feel like there's a cap is when I
was a post I was like leading my project
I was in charge I was determining the
scope and the future of that project and
here I'm just uh a part of something
which is also really exciting but then
you feel like a sense of less control in
a way and more directed and I kind of
wanted to see what you guys thought of
that
thanks um my experience has been
that like the job levels within data
science are uh are very tied to how much
Direction versus self-direction you're
going to engage in so when you come in
as like a Bas level data scientist or
analyst your work is very highly scoped
for you it tends to be like execute this
solution to to oversimplify it um you
move up a level and now you're being
asked you know find a solution to this
problem that I'm giving you you move up
a another level to staff and now you're
being asked choose which problems are
worth
solving and so like as you move up your
scope uh and the amount of autonomy and
responsibility you have for for for
directing your work um it keeps
increasing um but so yeah I would say
like you know your experience is yeah as
you get started your work tends to be
more scoped but then as you demonstrate
that you can choose good Solutions and
choose problems worth solving you tend
to be given more and more autonomy and
then you know the uh responsibility and
promotions go with that
yeah I think I think the other thing
that kind of your question by the way
I'm loving this chat there's so much
like good sharing from everybody um but
one of the other things that I was
thinking about too is that essentially
right with any job and any organization
there are trade-offs and so I think one
of the big trade-offs with Academia in
theory at least is that with Academia
you're supposed to get like full
intellectual Freedom although hard to
get until you get tenure but you know in
theory you get full academic freedom and
you can kind of P and set a lot of your
um your own schedule and and your work
and the reason I think you can do that
is that you're a lab or where you work
kind of um they act autonomously right
they're in their own line of research
Etc when you go into a company
especially the bigger the company gets
there's just more interdependencies
right you're trying to work on things
that affect and and interact with more
people but the trade-off for that is
that oftentimes the impact on the reach
is also very different right so in
Academia you're kind of in your little
little area you want to make an impact
oftentimes people do it by building a
body of work after many many decades um
in Industry you kind of get that
trade-off where I mean the example I
think of is I worked at thread up um
where you know we're a medium by the
time I left we were like a mediumsized
company we were public I have friends
who worked at meta where when they send
an email to their customer base it goes
out to 50 million people right and so
like their scope is is actually large
but their inter interdependencies are
also incredible and the amount of cross
functional work they have to do is very
very high compared to what I had to do
um so I think you just get that that
tradeoff um depending on where you go
and is that kind of a challenge when it
comes to even hiring pure academics
where they kind of have that is that one
of the challenges when hiring people who
are more traditionally academic and
transitioning into this or do you find
that people often quickly transition and
that's not really something you're
thinking of um when hiring people from
traditionally academic
background um I think this goes into
that translation piece uh I can think of
three hiring examples where we took
someone right out of Academia and they
started at a staff level um that's
that's two levels up from an entry-level
position in data science and we did that
because they demonstrated ability to
scope and direct their work based on
their academic
experience um like those are those soft
skills that I was saying they're really
hard to find but if you can translate
you know that soft scale into terms that
you know your hiring manager can
understand you can um you know you can
come in at a very high level uh if if
you don't come in at such a high level I
think nonetheless you would rapidly rise
to that level because as I said it's a
rare skill set and so if you demonstrate
it um you you will be given you know the
additional autonomy and responsibility
um because you know we need people to do
that kind of
work thank you thank you I see um Jared
you had asked the question a little bit
earlier about different educational
backgrounds for data science do you want
to jump in hi Rachel can you guys hear
me okay yep yeah so I guess my question
is just more of a blanket statement but
given just from these data science hang
in general people come from such a wide
variety of backgrounds when it comes to
uh data scientist positions have you
guys found that there are certain
educational backgrounds
or I mean not just technical skills
we've talked about soft skills but
really just focused on like educational
backgrounds that help seem to to put
people in a better position or seem to
be more common than others and kind of
demonstrate a road for
Success if you're ready oh Joe maybe
actually I'll I'll jump in your answer
yeah yeah yeah um
so the word self uh Reliance comes to
mind um an incredibly diverse background
among the people I work with uh and
oftentimes they learned their initial
data skill set in service of you know
some small business they were running or
some side hustle uh one of my favorite
stor one of the guys I work with he was
an online Gambler and got really
sophisticated about it and um you know
you could see how that would play into
like predictive modeling and the data
science workflow and uh I tend to really
see a lot of that where it's just you
know they're very like self-driven and
self- engaged with their with their
education and you know not sure how many
on the call today are are academics I'm
seeing in the chatter that there's a lot
but you know you know
that big part of a PhD is self-education
you know the the coursework is not um
like really the emphasis you have to
teach yourself a lot of skills around
programming or figure out how to get the
resources you need to learn those new
skills and um so that's the background I
see because you're going to continuously
be learning on the job and so if you can
demonstrate that you have a history of
doing that I think that's what sets you
up for success or those like that
mindset that you know you can uh you can
find the resources you need to to learn
the next thing
[Music]
um yeah I I think also um I think one
thing that's kind of challenging about
data science as a field I think and I
would say the same coming from product
is that it's a more it's a newer field
right it's a little bit younger than
like software engineering or or some
other um Fields where that those fields
have been a little bit more defined for
longer their programs you can get an
undergrad in engineering they're like
clear leveling paths you know in these
tech companies that have been
established for a long time data science
is a little bit relative to some of
these other areas is still evolving
quite quickly the technolog is changing
very fast the methods are changing you
know even our approach to like AB
testing I feel like over the last five
years has got has gone through like
multiple revolutions and so I think that
is one of the challenges for people
coming into it is figuring out okay well
how do I position myself what do I spend
time like investing skills in and I
think to this point I think I agree with
Joe I think the ability to learn new
things and figure out um like where to
learn and grow next is really important
kind of our earlier point about talking
to people and actually figuring out
what's on The Cutting Edge of the field
and what might be worth worth it and
what might not be is really important
and then I think like for academics this
is actually not dis similar I think to
your PhD research is that often times
those fields are changing if the methods
are changing you want to figure out the
best method to answer the question that
you're looking for and you may need to
learn new things um so so I do want to
call out like I do think that's
something there's not a very standard
standard path that like if you just do
these things things will be guaranteed
um and that can make it very tricky it
also means that you know kind of what
Joe is saying your technical skills are
not enough you have to have this
combination of technical skills and the
ability to sort of navigate
organizations and talk to people and
build relationships because I think it's
the combination of those two things that
makes people um that actually helps
them there's yeah there's a piece there
that ties a few themes together which is
like we mentioned like informational
interviewing earlier so you know you
learn how to talk about yourself you
learn about where you're interested
you're also going to learn what data
science means at that company uh it's
not a standardized definition um and
I'll say I have generally found there
are two verticals uh there's like a
machine learning AI vertical uh that
tends to be about like automating
decision making so you're automating
small decisions like what should I put
in my cart next what should I watch next
and then there's an analytics vertical
and that tends to be very thoughtfully
constructing big decisions like which
Market should we pursue next um you know
which product feature should we launch
next um and those are very different um
and you know you may find that you're
more qualified for one or the other if
you have a ton of machine learning and
Predictive Analytics experience like
maybe going down that ml path is going
to be really promising for you um if
you're really into like Theory building
and like understanding customer Behavior
Uh anal that analytics vertical can be a
fantastic fit um because they're not
going to call it Theory building but
like what are you doing like you're
developing customer narratives you're
trying to understand customer behavior
and then you're trying to change that
behavior in you know hopefully positive
ways um
and that is very close to the theory
building that you did as an academic
they're just again translating they're
not going to call it Theory and Industry
they're going to call it like narrative
and context and so I saw a great comment
about can I count my years of PhD and
postto experience as industry experience
absolutely um if you can convince the
hiring manager that those years were
relevant experience then they
count um and in my mind they count and
and you should be very confident in
claiming that they count
I love in the beginning we were talking
about like everybody's first jobs and we
were commenting in the chat but also in
Hangouts before we've talked about all
the different kinds of paths that people
take to get to the roles that they're in
now and I know not everybody is going to
have a PhD of course to go into to data
science um but I was wondering if you
have other guidance for people in that
position when maybe the job posting is
is calling for that like how do you get
past that well maybe I I'll start um I I
think like one thing I do want to kind
of set the tone on is that there is in
in in in my ideal world when it comes to
hiring you know how you would do things
is that you actually like think about
the job that you need to hire for you
step back and you really think about
what competencies we're really trying to
hire for right and then you try to find
candidates who have the ability or the
potential to like meet those
competencies and those competencies are
you know whatever skills we're looking
for and are somewhat like unrelated to I
saw a note about like a Stanford PhD are
unrelated to like the school you went to
whether or not you have a PhD like it's
very unclear to me if the PHD is the
most efficient way to get any of these
skills right so like even though both
Joe and I have it like we could have a
different conversation about whether or
not the PHD is the right thing to do um
right and so
um so like so so I think that's like
kind of the ideal world and actually a
lot of the research on sort of um good
hiring practices supports this General
model where like you actually want to
think about the competencies and you
actually want to hire for people who
have those competencies no matter how
they got them now the reality of the
world is a little bit different than
that which is that hiring managers are
often using proxies to try to get at
those things right they'll use the
degree as a proxy they might use the
school that you went to as a proxy and
so I just kind of want to say that out
loud as like the first kind of the
context which is the world is not at the
ideal stage I think that many of us
would want to be and so we have to both
like um I was once told you know you
want to move the world towards the world
that you want it to be but also
recognize the realities and like address
the realities right on so I think when
there are certain requirements that are
on there hard requirements I think you
do have to do a little bit more work
basically to try to convince somebody
but I do think that that work is
possible and again it kind of goes back
to I think some of the same themes which
is like if you have a soft intro to the
hiring manager or you've talked to
somebody internally that's a much easier
case I think to kind of get your name in
the the game and and actually get that
conversation and show that you have
those competencies um I think another
way is um I've seen some incredible
resumés where they didn't have sort of
the requirements that maybe were listed
um but they had a way of basically um
articulating the skills that we were
looking for or even in the way that they
constructed the resume showed us that
they would be able to communicate these
things very well so there are things
like that but I think in today's like
hiring environment which is a little
tighter than it was you know a couple
years ago like one of the the biggest
things I would say is like if you can
find a way to get yourself in front of
the the recruiter or the hiring manager
like getting in that door is probably
one of the hardest steps I think in in
today's hiring environment but
Joe um so think Rachel's initial
question was like you know if you don't
have the PHD background like you know
how how can you prepare yourself um for
this track
and yeah I think like Jen and I were
alluding
like getting a PhD is not the efficient
way to gain these skills it just happens
to be the way that uh we took um I can
tell you my counterpart in the other H
the other side of the company has no PhD
we have the same title like uh you know
and his 401k is probably in way better
shape um
so uh you don't need a PhD um it's just
that you know I wanted to say like if
you have one like there are some skills
you inefficiently gained along the way
that now you can capitalize on um but if
if you're not going that route um
actually I heard some wonderful advice
uh from someone I was speaking to at
posit conference uh they applied at
Apple um and the hiring manager told
them gave some great feedback they were
like you're not ready yet but here's my
advice um get a job as an analyst at a
small Insurance Company um and and the
idea was that then have access to some
like great highly relevant data and and
the idea was just like while you're in
that small shop just like knock their
socks off um you know like use all of
the great like open- Source free
resources that are available in r&
Python and just like build yourself an
amazing portfolio and I think this was
amazing advice because actually getting
a hold of relevant data with signal in
it um is hard uh it's not available at
every company but like an insurance
company probably does have it you know
there's like the right incentives to get
uh that kind of data in place so I think
you know if you put yourself in that
kind of environment where you have
access to that data and then you use it
to build up your skills and demonstrate
your skills like you know at the end of
the day like when you're hire when
you're when you're interviewing you're
only going to get to tell like two or
three stories
you know I mean like it's it's actually
quite limited how much of yourself
you're going to get to show so like you
know you think about like okay you know
you you know you have a resume with some
bullet points of like things you've
accomplished and you have two or three
persuasive stories if you're really
ambitious like I would recommend
starting a blog so that you can like you
know do more publication not publication
in the formal sense but just publicizing
of you know your ability to communicate
and to make um compelling narrative and
comp in data is um but that that would
be very ambitious I rarely see that even
among people we hire a Blog would be a
like you know very impressive but but
just again you know find a position
where you have access to some
interesting data and and then kind of
just kind of keep building your skills
incrementally from there and
demonstrating it um yeah you don't need
the PHD uh to do this kind of work it's
more of that self-starter
self-reliance that uh PhD really
requires so it becomes like a signal of
that ability but it's not the only way
um it's like we said it's a very
inefficient way it takes five or six
years um
so I see um Mike you have your hand
raised you want to jump in
here thanks for that um it actually
wanted to come back to something that
Jen just said which I think is really
important the it's it's almost like the
CV screening process is done by people
who don't actually you know they're
they're they're using something just to
go in out in out rather than you know a
holistic look at what actually that
person can do you know and so it's like
that that kind of screening filtering
happens way before anyone who has a data
science background might even look at
your
CV sorry I may be putting words in your
mouth Jen but you know it it seems to me
that any those kinds of things are
completely arbitrary and completely
unfair because they happen so far
removed from the hiring manager
sometimes that I'm wondering how we
redress that I think well I I think
between Joe and I we have experiences
with like a wide range of companies
right so Joe um has worked for startups
all the way to big companies and so I
guess like I would say kind of two
things here one is um so I'll give two
examples of my job search which wasn't
um I was actually looking at data
science jobs when I first um entered the
market so a couple things one and I I'm
going to give my example but it's an
extreme example so just like take so I
kind of knew in December um I defended
my dissertation in May I knew in
December that I wanted to go into
industry so I just used that time to
informational interview and I had these
hypotheses and I just talked to a lot of
people um I talked to a lot of people I
ended up because I had never done a job
in Tech I had no idea what a recruiter
was I was like why am I talking who is a
recruiter like what do they do um so I
did over a hundred informational
interviews over six months which again
is Extreme I was like writing my
dissertation and had more flexibility um
but the reason I like to tell this story
is that by the time that I applied to
jobs I only applied to maybe eight jobs
it was an extremely targeted search
because I kind of knew which cultures
and teams would align with what I was
looking for and I had um some contact at
almost every place that I applied for
and I think really notably the two
places where I didn't have any contact
fact I never heard back from I did not
make it past the resume screen but all
of the places where I knew a little bit
more or had somebody who was like a
third connection um I ended up
interviewing and and was able to to get
an offer so I think like that's kind of
one story is really around um the the
the power of when I tell this story I
often tell people you'll either have to
do a lot of work by applying to a lot of
jobs right and do kind of a scattershot
approach and just see who bites or you
could do a lot of work up front and talk
to a lot of people people and then do a
more selective search so the work is
there either way um and then the second
thing I would say is I think it really
depends on stage of company right so my
general impression though Joe you have
way more experience than me is that I
think some of these things are harder in
larger organizations because they're
just more systems right they're getting
a lot of people it's a larger system
they're more screens they're recruiters
if you go smaller and this is kind of
the advice that I was given for for um
product at the time I was told that
basically it would be impossible for me
to get a product management job with no
previous experience and I think that
that is basically true um to try to
break into product at a large company
would have basically been almost
impossible I think at the time but it
turns out that when I go to a smaller
company they're looking for very
different things they're looking for
people who are self starters they're
also they don't have as much leverage
for hiring because they can't pay as
much as like the Big Fang companies
could at the time and in that situation
like I was able to talk directly to the
hiring manager early on Etc so I think
like the stage of company also will
dictate one how formal their system is
two how many layers you have to go
through and then three maybe how
accessible it is to chat with people um
but that's my that that's kind of been
my impression and experience but Joe you
might have a lot more to add yeah um
sorry I just saw you know your um ID it
was Smith MK I didn't I didn't catch
your name um but
Yeah you mentioned like Mike okay
applying through the online portal uh I
never do it um and for the simple reason
that like even with the great
credential um I would routinely get desk
rejected um
it's it requires networking you know
like cold calls on LinkedIn finding
people who are second and third degree
contacts and asking for introductions
now I will admit that for many people
even for me that is painful and unwanted
activity but you can flip that around
and think of it as your advantage that
most people aren't willing to engage in
that kind of um you
know door like knocking on doors
essentially uh cold calling to get
network their way in now once you get
like that referral now you have a much
more High higher likelihood of actually
getting like you know the initial part
of the interview
started um but that kind of networking
doesn't
end um at the interview process like
that's big part of the job too I mean
once you're internal so you know
congratulations you've now been hired
and you know you're doing work well
you're still going to need to figure out
how to network within your company in
order for you know your projects to get
green lit for your projects to go into
production um that is a skill unto
itself too and so if I see you know
candidates um who are doing that
networking in order to get um you know
that internal referral like that's a
good signal to me that like they're
going to be willing to do the kind of
personal networking when they're inside
the company as well um you know
submitting to the portal and like hoping
for the best is just such low likelihood
and and once you're inside like
finishing your project and pushing to
GitHub and like hoping for the best is
like that's not going to be enough you
know you're going to need to figure out
like who's buying do you need get their
feedback in advance it's like they're
completely parallel processes getting
into the company and then performing
once you're inside the
company a question that I love to ask in
the Hangouts um is what's a piece of
career advice that you've received or
maybe that you've given that stands out
to you I don't know if Jen you want to
start with this one sure so actually
mine is um Joe Joe and I discussed this
like years ago so when I was looking for
my first job I think Joe like maybe you
and Bella had this heuristic or
something which is like in any job you
can really only optimize for two things
or at least that's like a way of
thinking about it it's like you can only
optimize for two things and everything
else that you get is like bonus or or um
is great that it comes with a package
but once you try to optimize for more
than two things the the equation gets
like very complicated and the the set of
jobs that you can take might become too
narrow so an example is if you care
about geography pay Mission culture um
growth you know you can list all these
values that you have and that you want
out of your next job um it probably is
like doable to get something where
you're Mission aligned and get like a a
salary or comp package that you're happy
with um it's probably possible to get a
geography and a comp package that you
want it's much harder to try to get all
three in that first job or in the
current job that you want and so I
really love this piece of advice because
there are a couple underlying principles
here one is that it means that you need
to get really clear on what you want
right and I think that some people um
and I've fallen this into this myself
too it's like people approach you with a
job you get excited about it but you
actually didn't start from a place where
you were really grounded in your own
values and what's really important to
you so I think that's great starting
point is really thinking about like what
do you want um and what's most important
to you in this next step
and then the second piece that I really
like about this piece of advice is that
um and and there are many other
Frameworks I've heard people be like
list your top three priorities and three
extra criteria etc etc um but the other
thing I like about this is that it
really puts me at least in a mindset
where careers are not made by one job
right so just because in that one job
you're optimizing maybe say for um comp
and geography doesn't mean that your
entire career will will not be um
focused on culture Mission and things
like that and um I think thinking of you
know your career and your jobs as steps
along the way that's building like a
larger career portfolio um has been
really useful for me so um I think you
need to think about what are your
non-negotiables like one of them for me
is is culture um and uh and so but but
within that I think just having a sense
of
prioritization um is really useful so
thanks
Joe
um I think like a really good piece of
advice
is it's easy to think you need to build
a lot of new skills in order to get make
a transition and and and I don't think
that's true I think you should focus on
polishing your existing
skills rather than building new ones
once you're in the job then you can
build new ones but just you have a lot
more skills than you realize
and if you just polish those and then
like refine them you know if you're
doing multiple regression in your work
great but I want you to know multiple
agression like all the way down to the
foundations uh before you know you don't
need to start learning like every
machine learning technique in the book
um you know you can get a first job just
on multiple regression um but know it
really well um and it's tied to that
though
is that doesn't mean that the job you're
qualified for now is going to sound
exactly like your PhD
dissertation I I see a lot of people
like overly narrowly Define themselves
because that's what Academia promotes
you to do is you're like you get very
narrowly defined in your identity and
then you look for a job that sounds like
that and and I just encourage you to be
open-minded
um you know think more about like you
know if you if you have a background and
like you know science or like diversity
and
inclusion um you know yeah there are job
titles that are called like diversity
and inclusion officer and that's open to
you or and you could be a product
manager and just bring that amazingly
unique perspective uh to the role and be
an amazing product manager or a people
manager who builds a team where people
can Thrive it it doesn't need to be your
formal job title that Maps like exactly
to your um you know your PhD
dissertation uh you know you can just
bring that perspective to a traditional
role and Excel at
it Russ I see you have your hand raised
do you want to add something here uh yes
can you hear me yep I can okay uh
something different but I think
extremely important to hear I work as a
professional recruiter I'm transitioning
in data science this has nothing to do
with data science this is encouragement
for all of you who have been in the
situation I'm about to describe for my
friend I've been working with a friend
at the same company for I don't know
four or five years my friend you know
transfer got promoted transferred got
promoted and W up in a spot that was not
good I found out two days ago my friend
was
fired okay so I contacted my friend I
said hey let me rewrite your resume you
know put on qualifications stuff like
that because I can do that and my friend
already has interviews lined up what it
means is my friend did really well in
work environment so one two three and
four but number five was a bad match
that's not a reflection of my friend my
friend's going to keep going moving
forward if you've had bad experiences we
all have that's it's not a reflection on
you it's just a bad match keep moving
forward that's how you
succeed
absolutely I have to agree I feel like
you know part of the we've talked about
like the hard skills and the soft skills
and then the other kind of career skill
overall is that um we're all just people
trying to figure out what work
environment works best for us and what
kind of people we want to work with and
what kind of problems and you know this
is something I think people are not
talking about when you're younger in
school
which is you might like the subject but
do you like the day-to-day is there a
particular management style that you
like you know what's the mix of meetings
and focus time that works best for you
and I think thinking about your career
as an explor as a self- exploration to
understand what works best for you is
ultimately kind of what this is all
about so one job is just one job but
it's all building a body of knowledge um
to figure out what works best for every
single person which is going to be
different and that's exciting I think
Eugene I I know this was a bit earlier
I'm not sure if you're or you are still
on um but you had a comment around like
this idea of being obsessed with
correctness and when businesses don't
necessarily um prioritize on that do you
want to jump in
here um
sure
um I've had I have a lot of academic
training um and I've never been much of
an academic uh person I feel very
pragmatically driven it was like 20% of
the work was getting new results but 80%
was always saying how wrong they might
be and Reporting on the different ways
to do things that might end up wrong or
where your data came from and I I never
enjoyed that part of it um but the
people that I've worked with uh the more
academic they are and one of the closest
people I work closest with right now is
an
mdphd and it never feels like some of
the tasks that we work on together are
done enough or correct enough or
accurate enough and it creates
this I can never really tell the people
who depend on our
deliverables how done he feels you know
or a a former uh co-worker you know we
were we were fine tuning Financial
marketing models together and he would
say but this is wrong this is not the
way to do it and I would constantly have
to say it does the data validate that
there is lift or that we're getting
incremental you know uh lift or that the
modeling is actually producing you know
gains um you know would it work if you
put this in you know does the data show
that this might work and he would say
yes but this is not the right way to do
it so it was this I felt like when
working with a lot of academics they
they they wanted so much more
completeness and accuracy you know and
and certainty about about their approach
to be um validated by research validated
by other you know people who know the
exact way to do small statistics large
statistics I mean I think one of the
funniest things you know you guys can
Riff on this as long as you want but
when you get into Big Data every single
thing you measure is statistically
significant every single one so what do
you do when every possible number you
know has error bars this tiny um and and
it's really hard to get people past you
know that that frame of mind from what
my experience is with academics in in
business okay I think that that actually
points out a good transition uh point of
like what are the standards you're
working to you know if you are doing
basic research and you're trying to
build knowledge uh then having this like
exclusive body of rigorous findings is
the
goal
um that's not the goal at most
businesses you know again you know if
you're doing like medical research then
you know that's that's different like
you actually there is more of a
scientific goal in there but um
oftentimes you know you think of like
businesses are often it's more of like
an investment strategy and so now it's
not about like building an exclusive
body of knowledge it's about really
optimal stopping how long should we
explore for so that we can you know
exploit that knowledge uh for maximum
gain and that's a different um that's a
different standard it's not a lower
standard it's it's a different goal and
then that that goal brings with it a
different standard so that's a change of
mindset that uh you should be prepared
to make um you know like it's not going
to serve you well to bring over like
academic standards to an environment
where those won't serve you um so yeah
most business bus settings going to be
more about optimization than they are
about um you know building scientific
knowledge uh although there will be some
overlap but yeah it's a different
standard is my
um answer yeah and Eugene your question
kind of reminds me of a a conversation I
had very early on when I first got into
industry um which was that you know in
in Academia what we care about is um if
if you get a result like let's say you
run an experiment and
you know your null result is like
nothing or your you know the the kind of
the worst case is basically nothing
changes right like that's like in
Academia that's like the worst case now
you don't have anything that you can
report on but if you get an unexpected
result either way it's more positive
than you thought or it's more negative
than you thought now you have an
interesting result and you can talk
about it and try to figure out causality
and all these things in business kind of
to Joe's point if Academia is about
building knowledge in business I say a
lot of the times it's just about
reducing risk so a lot of the time the
standard of decision-making is we don't
want um actually a good result would be
like that nothing changes or it's
positive and the bad result is if it
makes the the outcomes that we care
about worse right and so that's that to
me is such a fundamental change in how
you look at it because if you are trying
to be like oh should we roll out this
change in our business really what a lot
of leaders care about is they just want
to make sure that it doesn't make things
worse right and so either if it's the
same or better then that's great but
that same result in Academia if it's the
same is seen as like a not very valuable
result and and I think that that shift
is quite fundamental and um and it's
understandable I think that many people
struggle with that shift because you
know you're in any organization with its
own values set and things like that you
do absorb that way of thinking and
sometimes it needs to be called out
extremely explicitly to help people
understand how they were thinking before
um because before in Academia everybody
thought this way there was no need to
call it out at all you know and so
sometimes it's hard to identify when
you're actually in a different kind of
cultural
environment I know this time goes by so
quickly um so one other um question I
I'd love for us to get to is I I know a
lot of us are in a position where we're
hoping to advance our career maybe get
the next promotion and was wondering
what advice you may have for some of us
who are in that position right now you
we talked earlier about like
networking um and I think that you
know promotion is often has a
um it has a social component um it's not
to say it's popularity contest it is to
say like you need to be well aligned
with you know your lead your managers
and leaders about like what skills uh
what demonstr ations are going to
Warrant uh that promotion and
so um you know if you're if you're
seeking promotion within your company
like my advice would be like start that
as an explicit conversation um you know
with your manager about like what are
the skills that you know you need to see
demonstrated what are the you know
accomplishments that you know you need
to see so that it's not like a mystery
that arrives at the end of the year but
it's like an explicit uh
conversation um and then you know you
don't have to you don't have to stop
there like you know look around at who
else is getting promoted uh you know
within your org and like reading between
the lines of like okay well what have
they accomplished that distinguished
them from you know the rest of their
their peers and um I think that you
know getting aligned on expectations but
also like just being a lot of this just
keeps coming back to like being very
resourceful and self-driven about like
finding a path um to uh to your goals
and um you know if you're willing to do
that I think you have a lot more
opportunity uh to to attain
promotion yeah I think um yeah we keep
coming back to the same themes over and
over right which is like you need to
find a way to carve your own path to
some extent when it's not that clear and
and talking to people I think for
promotion um one story kind of comes to
mind of um kind of earlier when I had
first jumped to Industry which is I was
a very process oriented person you know
I really believe that if you set up good
good processes you basically bias all of
your outcomes towards um everything is
kind of I looked at things like very
probabilistically so I was like I'll set
up a good process that means that you
know the probability that I get a better
outcome is sort of determined at in
terms of how you make those decisions so
I used to I spent my first six months on
the job just talking all about these new
processes I had implemented and how
great they were um and I have I got
feedback that was kind of like we're an
outcomes driven organization Jen like
all this talk of process not like it's
not doing it for us and I I remember my
first reaction was just sort of like
frustration I was like come on the
process is so important um but I think
it kind of goes to this advice which is
that uh different organizations will
value different things and um every
organization is its own little fum with
its own set of values so you want to
spend time getting that feedback
figuring out what actually matters and
how it's talked about and how it's
framed
I ended up taking a lot of the same
things that I used to talk about from a
process perspective and I just kind of
framed it and was able to show how it
led to Pro to outcome and I would really
focus on talking about the outcomes and
it was a total turnaround in terms of
how people perceived the contributions
that I made even though it was the same
kind of work right so I think that's one
thing is like figure out what matters to
the org um and then the second thing I
would say about promotion is that
increasingly I think at some levels you
know depending on your track the
promotions end up being like similar
work but also at a certain point there's
some promotions that lead to jobs that
have like different it's like a
different job right like I kind of at
some point was in ic and went to a
manager and it was ended up being a very
different job and so one last thing I
kind of wanted add to add here is that
increasingly now I am kind of um I
increasingly I'm I'm trying to really
step back and be like is this a
promotion I actually want and is this
kind of promotion at this company the
kind of promotion that I want because
there there are times in my career so
far where the work that I've loved to do
the most was actually when I was kind of
in a different role and had slightly
different responsibilities and so
obviously now with a bit of like
hindsight and reflection I can think
about what are the elements that I
really loved but this goes back to our
earlier point about how I think ultim
all of this is really about trying to
figure out what's the right fit for you
um and sometimes that's correlated with
role and title and sometimes that's not
and sometimes it's correlated with role
and title at your company but may not be
correlated somewhere else um so just
kind of the broader just wanted to
mention that I'll I'll tag on one more
thing I just thought of which was
um so into it they have this uh
principles Community um so they get all
of the principal level like engineers
and data scientists together and you
know we like talk um and
one thing that came out of that meeting
recently that was really interesting was
just like this theme of like willingness
to take informed
risk you know um
like and I think this is actually like
in hindsight like a really important
theme of like you
know promotion is not assured uh you
know like you're probably going to have
to take some informed risks and maybe
that means like investing your time and
learning a new modeling technique or a
new you know um you know I don't know
what that's going to be for you um but
that means like investing time and you
know and like you're taking a risk like
maybe um maybe it won't work out you're
not going to get you know promoted on
that project but it was something that
came out of a lot of people
independently in that room was like it
that willingness to take informed risk
and maybe there were a lot of people who
weren't in the room because their
informed risks like didn't work out but
uh it I I think that that willingness uh
to to like to you know to take a bet on
yourself um and like you know pursue
something that not everyone else is
doing uh can be really important if
you're seeking
promotion yeah thank you so much I I
think that that question had been top of
mind for me lately because I was talking
to somebody who was saying they like
saved like their whole work week they
saved 40 hours a week by doing like
parameterized Cordo documents and they
were advocating for a promotion for
themselves and I was thinking wow that's
amazing you just made all this new time
for yourself like you you could possibly
use that in getting this promotion um
and just like kind of flipping that that
mindset a little bit Yeah well yeah I
mean that's a great example that wasn't
something that was defined for them like
no one was saying oh this is how you
should do your job like they took a
totally new approach to how to
accomplish their job and saved an
enormous amount of time and I think
those kind of examples are like great
ways to demonstrate that you have the
like scoping and autonomy abilities that
warrant the next level absolutely well I
feel like we could all keep talking
about this stuff for ever and this hour
went by really really quickly but thank
you so much Jen and and Joe for joining
and sharing your experience with us all
this has been great yeah thank you the
questions have been so thoughtful I've
just been I've been learning a lot from
the questions I'm like oh this great
questions it is really fun to to read
through the chat so if anybody wants to
see the chat there's those little three
dots on the bottom there and you can
just click save chat too um but Jen and
Joe if people want to get connected with
you as LinkedIn the best pleas yeah yeah
okay awesome well thank you all so much
have a great rest of the day thank you
bye everybody bye thank
you